hello everybody I'm Jesse waters along
with Juan Williams Greg Gutfeld shannon
bream and kennedy it's 5 o'clock in new
york city and this is the 5
[Music]
huge day of news from the White House
President Trump set to hold another
coronavirus briefing minutes from now
and earlier today the president taking
action to address surging violence and
chaos in cities it comes as 15 people
were injured in a drive-by shooting in
Chicago the city's mayor now finally
willing to accept help from President
Trump while murders surged by 50 percent
from last year the president announcing
he's authorizing federal agents already
working in US cities to help local
police fight crime this bloodshed must
end this bloodshed will end no mother
should ever have to cradle her dead
child in her arms simply because
politicians refuse to do what is
necessary to secure their neighborhood
and to secure their city murderers and
violent criminals are breaking a wide
range of federal laws we have that it's
as wide as it can be we will find them
arrest them and prosecute them they will
be in jail for many years to come and in
Portland protestors continuing to clash
with federal agents the Department of
Homeland Security says it will not
retreat while Democrats like Nancy
Pelosi compare them to Nazi storm
troopers the Trump administration
hitting back
take a look I'm disgusted CRIF look so
far this year
CBP just CBP alone we've lost 10
personnel 10th in the line of duty and
for her to refer to those men and
women's stormtroopers that is that is
Error it's absolutely disgusting it's
just reckless and it's untrue all right
Shannon the language that liberals are
using to describe federal law
enforcement officials absolutely
disgraceful they're there to just arrest
anarchists protect federal property stop
illegal gun trafficking and and now
they're compared to Nazis just
disgusting yeah and they're super
frustrated these are people who were out
on the front lines trying to protect and
save lives
you know congressman Bobby Rush who is a
Democrat from Illinois where they have
massive problems this is actually what
he said today that the president wants
to instigate a race war quote he wants
to have
black folks fighting white folks so he
can rise up and say I'm the real Grand
Wizard of the Ku Klux Klan and I'm the
president reelect me I mean these
accusations are incredible and when this
thing is politicized it gets away from
the people like the ones we saw today at
the White House with the president who
are family members of these victims the
mother of legend Telfer oh absolutely
heartbreaking and I think when Americans
see her and hear her story it's tough to
watch that without getting choked up and
think about this four-year-old who
describes you know he fights he fought
back against open-heart surgery when he
was four months old you saw the man
talking about his wife Jackie who was
ambushed and killed in Albuquerque I
mean it's got to be personal and I think
the president the White House were smart
to have those folks out there because if
you're watching that regardless of what
party no party whoever you are
your heart has to break for these
situations and it shouldn't be turning
into a situation where we're demonizing
federal agents and we're accusing people
of being Nazis or wanting to instigate a
race war you know one I know you do not
agree with that kind of language used
against American law enforcement
officials well in this case you know
Jesse I think this is a pure political
play Trump is trying to change the
conversation
no no one is saying do you of the Koran
upgrade Selassie you went on and on
Jesse you went on and on can I speak for
a second because look what he's got here
is Trump I'm answering the question I'm
telling you this president is trying to
change the conversation away from his
failed handling of the coronavirus all
right and I'm telling you this is the
same tactic he used before 2018 when he
was telling people that a caravan and a
threatening Caravan was coming in crawl
on you dog makes like border and that
was the real problem no I'm not dodging
I'm answering and I maybe you don't want
to hear it but I thought I would hear
you say you disagree the Nazis won no
let me just I don't agree with anybody
calling anybody a Nazi but I'm going to
tell you what conservatives what
Republicans have to say about this Jesse
because I think you need to hear it the
conservative New York Post editorial
page today said mr. Trump don't send any
troops into New York City Tom
michael chertoff Republicans former
heads of Department of Homeland Security
havior this is former heads Republicans
of Department of Homeland Security in
fact Rizzo are you okay with the
violence in Chicago on the state can you
stop for a second I'm just telling you
that Ridge himself said today I don't
care what the DHS is not to become a
presidential militia the defense
secretary mark espera says he worries
about this action undermining Americans
trust and love of the military because
these men look like they are US military
in a domestic situation and I want you
Jesse to take a look at this tape
because this is mothers the wall of
mothers in Oregon taking a stand against
this frightful looking Trump agents with
all their arms and camouflage uniforms
and unmarked vans I also want you to
Jesse to take a look at this Navy
veteran wearing a t-shirt that says Navy
and he's being beaten beaten by these
men for what for asking them why aren't
they abiding by their constitutional
oath instead of coming out there this is
really a horrible moment I'm so glad
that local leaders and Americans of all
parties Republicans and Democrats are
taking a stand about one because the
task force may because you're buying it
ATF agents you're buying they're going
over the listings for illegal gang
members firing weapons into crowds
they're looking into illegal guns that
are on the streets they're trying to
solve crimes and they're trying to help
people live without getting shot by gang
members Kennedy what do you think about
the federal government coming into these
cities protecting federal property
arresting anarchists and trying to save
lives I understand the federal agents
who work in these federal buildings are
trying to protect the federal buildings
and when they're doing that lawfully
from within the confines of those
buildings and making sure that they are
not set ablaze with fireworks
Molotov cocktails that's okay I do have
a problem with the federal government
sending in agents from the outside to do
the job that local law enforcement is
supposed to do yeah but they're not they
are not they're not doing that because
the mayor's here are following they are
not leading and you know my family still
lives in Oregon and my brother works in
law enforcement just outside Portland
for a long time and you have a lot of
these law enforcement officers and
federal agents who are absolutely
exhausted because there isn't a curfew
like you had seen in places like
Minneapolis and New York and Los Angeles
and you know we're going on two months
straight of their protests that turn
into riots and if you're if you're
starting your protests at at 7:00 or
8:00 p.m. at sundown then that is
essentially a pre riot so if you have a
list of demands that you want go ahead
and make that known otherwise what you
are doing is actually eclipsing a
movement and you are you are lessening
the memory of George Floyd which is what
you purported to be doing in the first
place so local law enforcement if
they're not going to communicate with
federal law enforcement then they have
to take a hold of the situation so there
it is freedom and security for people
who live there that's not imposed by the
federal government Greg there's already
federal agents in every single city in
this country looking after fugitives
trying to find child sex traffickers
going after illegal guns and trying to
break up gangs that that just astounds
me that people to understand that it's
already happening they're just trying to
assist because these people can't do
their job but I just still can't believe
Juan would not condemn that these
Democrats calling us law enforcement
Nazis but you know the thing is it's it
really easy to disband a crime unit it's
really easy to mock police presence it's
really easy to reject government aid
when it's not your problem right I mean
I guess we should listen to one and
Nancy and take no for an answer
right if Portland doesn't want our help
let the city go to hell okay if that's
what they want
but I wished on a personal level that
somebody came to help me because my
problem was also a local problem I don't
want to belabor it but when my
neighborhood was attacked
it was assaulted and the damage I
believe is permanent true it was a local
problem
like all these local problems are in
Atlanta Minneapolis Santa Monica Seattle
Portland the Bronx all local problems
all abandoned by local politicians and
all mocked by the media because the
media doesn't live there the media
doesn't this is not their problem so
they call it a local problem I had an
epiphany
that when you when somebody looks at
lawlessness and says it's a local
problem you can do that to dismiss all
bad behaviors from even the smallest not
wearing a mask local problem vandalism
arson local problem gang violence local
problem police brutality
local problem how about how about slave
labor the wee girl ocol problem keep
buying your Nikes an earthquake that's a
local problem you can see how it
absolves the left of any moral judgment
they can dismiss anything and then the
reason why they do it it's not that it's
local problem it's that it's not their
problem so I say let him have it
let him have Portland let him see where
it goes
they've destroyed liberal cities by
becoming more and more liberal let it go
because they neva tably people are going
to have to move but when they move to
non liberal cities don't bring your crap
there don't bring your stupid ideas and
your toxic ideology to cities that don't
need it because you're gonna ruin them -
can I add something really quickly to
that in Los Angeles here it's very
interesting because when there actually
is a local problem that is not being
addressed and this is something that all
of these mayors in Portland Seattle all
the way down the west coast and beyond
its homelessness and now Eric Garcetti
here in Los Angeles is trying to appeal
to the president for federal help for
the local problem of homelessness so
again when it's convenient Greg is
absolutely right then they want federal
aid and imp
it's very hypocritical all right